je vous laisse sinon revenir sur un
point de un point de méthode on peut pas
les je me suis renseigné le gouvernement
peut pas faire de rappel au règlement
mais en tout cas je constate que
contrairement à ce qui se passait ce
matin on vous disiez que vous vouliez
accélérer et où vous disiez pour
l'essentiel de vos amendements
identiques défendus on voit qu'il y a
une bascule
cette bascule on voit que c'est le tweet
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon je ne sais pas si
c'est un tweet ou un DM fail comme on
dit et si là trahi un secret je ne sais
pas si ça avait vocation à être public
ou si c'était un message privé qu'il a
twitté sans faire exprès ce qu'on
appelle un DM fail puisqu'il dit
incompréhensible retrait des amendements
du PCF pourquoi se précipiter l'article
7@ de se faire battre ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire on sait qu'on est
minoritaire on sait qu'on a pas de
majorité pour mettre en échec le
gouvernement et donc il faut faire
traîner les débats c'est ça que vous
dites c'est la vœu de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et regardez ce qui se passe dans
l'hémicycle regardez ce qui se passe
dans l'hémicycle les socialistes les
socialistes ils sont partis ils sont
partis probablement parce qu'ils sont
dégoûtés de cette stratégie
d'obstruction il reste trois écologistes
les communistes ils restent trois
personnes il y a plus que vous la France
insoumise parce que les autres ne
partagent pas votre obstruction
vous voulez pas qu'on ait le débat sur
les vrais sujets du projet de loi c'est
une admissible c'est inadmissible
accepter qu'on aille sur le fond et
qu'on débatte
madame la Présidente sur la base de
l'article 100 sur la bonne tenue des
débats
monsieur le ministre ce serait bien que
vous cessiez vos diversions qui visent à
nous empêcher de débattre des différents
amendements que nous avons déposés qui
sont des amendements utiles puisque nous
vous l'avons dit depuis le début nous
vous proposons de dégager de nouvelles
sources de financement nous aimerions
que ces débats soient examinés ces
amendements soient examinés dans leur
globalité de telle sorte à ce que
l'Assemblée nationale puisse se
prononcer sur ses amendements et dans
l'hypothèse ou l'un de ces amendements
seraient adoptés effectivement monsieur
le ministre dans ce cas là votre volonté
de reporter l'âge de départ à la
retraite n'aurait plus qu'à tomber aux
oubliettes pour le reste monsieur le
ministre s'il vous plaît si vous avez
vraiment l'intention de faire en sorte
que l'ensemble des articles l'article 7
certes l'article 8 l'article 9 l'article
10 l'ensemble des articles qui sont
soumis à dans ce projet de loi monsieur
le ministre si vous avez l'intention que
l'ensemble de ces articles soit débattus
il y a une solution extrêmement simple
prolonger les débats renoncer à
l'utilisation du 447 ans laissez-nous
débattre de l'ensemble de ce projet de
loi et nous le ferons avec plaisir et
pour le reste puisque ça ne vous dérange
pas de réagir à un tweet qui se passe à
l'extérieur de cette émission donc ça
veut bien dire que vous acceptez l'idée
de pouvoir répondre à des questions qui
sont pas directement le sujet des
amendements donc je me permets de vous
reposer un certain nombre de questions
monsieur le ministre est-ce qu'on peut
avoir la source des chiffres que vous
avez donné ce matin sur la source sur le
nombre de personnes qui pourraient
bénéficier de la retraite à 1200 euros
et est-ce que vous pouvez enfin répondre
à notre question pour savoir si oui ou
non quand vous avez commencé à
travailler à 16 ans à 17 ans ou à 18 ans
vous allez pas cotiser le même nombre
d'années répondez enfin à cette question
au lieu de faire diversion